foreign
welcome to build your infrastructure
modernization career with Google Cloud
credentials we're not just going to talk
about certification but also how you get
there how do you build your skills and
your career in Google Cloud
I'm Lisa Guin I'm a Google Cloud trainer
for infrastructure and I'm also a
professional Cloud architect I'm joined
by Anne and Alyssa
hi I'm Anne Henry I'm the learning
portfolio manager for infrastructure
modernization that includes networking
and security here at Google Cloud I'm
also an associate Cloud engineer
hi there I'm Alyssa Groves I'm a program
lead for Google Cloud certification
Readiness and I'm a certified Cloud
digital leader
now when we're talking about
certifications and credentials we're not
just talking about digital badges we're
also talking about how you can invest
and have a significant impact on your
organization how do you do that you ask
one you can build a company of cloud
experts and grow and showcase your
team's Cloud skills help them gain
confidence in their abilities and stay
current to give your company a
Competitive Edge you can increase
engagement in morale by showing your
employees that they're greatly valued by
your organization and that you're
invested in their success you can solve
your organization's toughest business
challenges quicker with a team that has
the right Cloud skills and finally you
can Inspire Innovation and drive new
ideas in your business find and attract
diverse Cloud Talent meet your strategic
objectives and boost your bottom line
now we talked about what you can do for
your team but what does this mean
personally Lisa and Ann what are your
thoughts
so Alyssa one of the things you talked
about was you talked about how people
need to
um have their credentials and upskill
their knowledge and build their careers
well this is where we're going to
concentrate on on this part here right
so we were going to upskill your
infrastructure knowledge so if you
already have an infrastructure Knowledge
from a data center what does it look
like in the cloud we want to kind of
build on that then once you've got the
the skills and everything let's get some
credentials for you let's show people
hey this is the cool stuff I can do I am
actually either a professional Cloud
architect I am a associate Cloud
engineer or possibly even a networker
security one right and then after you've
got your credentials you want to keep on
learning and uh Alyssa Elise and I have
talked about this in the past Lisa how
do you keep on learning well one of the
things of course you want to do is keep
on top of all the changes that come down
in Google Cloud every month every couple
of months there is some new product
that's worth checking out and you can
subscribe to one of the blogs and keep
up with that but how do you get Hands-On
with these things we'll talk a bit about
skills boost and the quick Labs that
give you a lot of opportunity for
Hands-On the trouble is there are
hundreds of Hands-On Labs how do you
pick and choose which ones will be the
best for your particular job your
particular career path and I think
that's one way that
certifications
really help direct what are we going to
do out of all the things we could be
doing with our time
in addition to those
um
Alyssa where do you find that like Cloud
credentials can help you like build
careers and teams
so yeah and as you can tell by now I
work in fours so I can split it up into
four different pillars so one it's gonna
help you have that validation and
credibility and you'll be able to
Showcase your Cloud skills to be able to
drive transformation for yourself but
also your organization you can also
future proof your career and in an
uncertain or unprecedented time such as
this is definitely important to do so
you also will be able to demonstrate
business impact and finally diversify
your connections now between these four
specific certifications can you kind of
talk about the differences between them
sure I can speak to the infrastructure
modernization I have both the associate
Cloud engineer and the professional
Cloud architect and in some ways they
cover the same ground because they're
pretty Broad in terms of covering all of
Google Cloud infrastructure they don't
emphasize the machine learning pieces
but otherwise it's pretty much
everything and yet they're quite
different the professional Cloud
architect is more focused on planning
and has case studies it's really about
the design aspects whereas the associate
Cloud engineer is more focused on
Hands-On actual implementation and I
think that sort of reflects the fact
that although a professional Cloud
architect does get involved with
implementation it's just a part of their
job so if you're thinking about one of
these two I would say the one that's
easier for you is likely to be the one
that aligns more with the job that you
do every day
oh that's my feedback on those two what
about networking and security and that's
more your area
yeah networking and security is very
much comes from the data center right so
you have people who've come from those
areas and they've either gone and either
physically plugged the wires set up
subnetting set up vlans on the
networking side and security they've set
up identity management they've set up
other ways of securing data at rest and
data in motion so depending on where
you're coming from and what your
specialty is and what's close to your
heart is probably what you're going to
concentrate on if you're coming from
data center over to Cloud so much like
the Asin PCA have have their areas of
expertise the PC and E which is the
networking one and the pcse have their
have their Specialties as well
so it really kind of depends on your
background and role right Lisa regular
stuff is that kind of what you're
running into a little bit
yes and maybe on what you already come
to Google Cloud knowing
so
that's very good one yeah
yeah that's that's very true
um for example uh this this slide here
shows a relative mapping right because
no cloud is created equal they're all
very different in different ways uh how
you would associate like the ace with
the Azure or AWS equivalent same with
the PCA right what's the equivalent for
the other two big clouds out there AWS
and is your security networking pretty
obvious because they have security
networking in their titles and you can
kind of figure that out but in today's
world we very much live in a multi-cloud
environment right and it's not that
we've built a multi-cloud from the
ground up it's we have maybe Alyssa's
Department set up their own little cloud
and say like Google cloud or Lisa set up
one in AWS and I've set up one in Azure
and they all need to speak to each other
and that's our multi-cloud so just
because you have one Cloud certification
doesn't mean it doesn't work to get
others right
yeah I think that is the the reality
that most large companies probably are
using more than one cloud in addition to
possibly having Legacy things in the
data center very true
I think it's also good that we have
courses that help people who have
backgrounds on other clouds to be able
to translate that knowledge into gcp so
for example on cloud skills boost we
have a course called Google Cloud
fundamentals for AWS and Azure
professionals so it really helps people
to be able to take those skills take
that knowledge and move it to a cloud
um into a multi-cloud approach and as
you can see on this slide there's a lot
of ways that you can learn so again the
fours
um you start with your instructor-led
training uh where our authorized
training partners are able to deliver
high quality and curate current content
for virtual or live classroom you have
your on-demand content where you can
learn anytime anywhere and then we have
our Hands-On Labs which we'll talk about
a little bit later but they allow you to
practice through a series of labs and
quests to gain experience in a sort of
sandbox environment government and then
finally our credentials and
certifications which brought us all here
today and they serve as a benchmark to
measure Cloud skills proficiency
so Ann could you maybe walk us through
an example of what this might look like
sure no problem Alyssa uh let's take the
professional Cloud security Engineers
Journey as a really great example this
one's a good one because it's got five
classes you can either take as either on
demand or you can take them in person
and there's about three things for
practicing and then after you're done
with all of that go look through the
exam guy go take sample questions go
take practice tests and that's when you
certify for the exam but before you even
certify for the exam Alyssa one thing I
did is I took the preparing for
Professional Security Cloud engineer
Journey course and I find it really
helpful because it showed me where my
strengths and where my weaknesses are
what do you find is the case with that
yeah I think that course is super
helpful we actually just developed it
and it's free to all regardless of your
Cloud skills boost subscription uh and
it allows you to go through different
modules to figure out where you're at
and really customize your learning plan
and your study plan for the journey and
then you also are able to take
diagnostic questions at the end of each
module to really test your knowledge so
I think that's a great place to start
for anyone who is starting a
certification Journey for sure that's
great how long you know this is for both
you and Lisa how long should it take
well I think that really depends on your
background that's one of the things that
the journey does as you mentioned it
gets you lined up for where you really
need to spend some time I think the
other thing that's cool in this learning
path are the skill badges because they
let you get some Hands-On practice but
they always end with a challenge lab if
you can complete the challenge lab then
you know you've got that skill under
your belt and if you don't well then you
can go back and do the labs again until
you're ready so I think you know the
journey is typically six to eight weeks
but a person might get it done quicker
or slower Alyssa what are the journeys
normally take
uh again like you said it all just
depends
um it's really about the preparation
that you put into it it's definitely an
investment but the more you put into it
the more you're going to get out of it
um so just take your time and really
walk through it as you can
yeah that's definitely important to walk
through it like as much as you can to
retain as much as you can well and
that's a good point and where are you
going to get started there are actually
a couple of resources that you have here
at next and then going forward the first
thing is there are some challenges that
you can do today at next it's called
Google cloud and you go to the dev Zone
and connect up with that but if you're
thinking hey I really want to get
started on this whole certification
Journey you can go to the class that
Anna and Alyssa mentioned by using the
30 days no cost trial training
subscription so just sign up for your
free 30-day subscription maybe if you've
already got a strong background you
could actually finish and be ready to
certify at the end of the 30 days
although I think most people will take
longer than that just depend again
depends on your background so once your
30-day trial is up hopefully you'll go
forward with the annual subscription
because they're always new things
happening in Google Cloud new projects
to do new team members who join so we
hope that you've gotten a lot out of
today's presentation and that you'll go
on and take some of these action steps
right away thank you Alyssa and Ann for
joining me today
thank you thank you
uh thank you everyone thank you all for
coming and participating in this talk I
hope you have a great time at next 22.
thank you